-Performing "Sun Sets
in Colorado" with Sam Bush
from his new album,
"Gravel & Gold,"
please welcome back
Dierks Bentley.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ My sun rose in a small town,
where I grew up way too fast ♪
♪ And some beach became my
college years
before it became my past ♪
♪ And California's
where I learned to dream,
but it never felt like home ♪
♪ It took a whole lot of miles
to find the place
where I belong ♪
♪ So won't you come out
here with me ♪
♪ And chase this
Rocky Mountain freedom? ♪
♪ Let that mile-high air
you breathe in ♪
♪ Wind you where
the river rolls ♪
♪ Yeah, we're born
where we're born ♪
♪ But I feel it deep down
in my bones ♪
♪ My heart beats in Tennessee ♪
♪ But my sun sets in Colorado ♪
♪ I've danced beside the ocean,
got my blue jeans wet
at high tide ♪
♪ My hands have reached
for heaven
from a New York City skyline ♪
♪ Oh, but nothing else compares
to the stardust on
the snowcaps ♪
♪ It's the kind of place
you leave
then you can't wait to go back ♪
♪ So won't you come out
here with me ♪
♪ And chase this
Rocky Mountain freedom? ♪
♪ Let that mile-high air
you breathe in ♪
♪ Wind you where
the river rolls ♪
♪ Yeah, we're born
where we're born ♪
♪ But I feel it deep down
in my bones ♪
♪ My heart beats in Tennessee ♪
♪ But my sun sets in Colorado ♪
♪♪
♪ Sing an old
New Grass song with me ♪
♪ Telluride along with me ♪
♪ Let's show 'em all
just how to be ♪
♪ Footloose
and wildflower-free ♪
♪ Won't you come out
here with me ♪
♪ And chase this
Rocky Mountain freedom? ♪
♪ Let that mile-high air
you breathe in ♪
♪ Wind you where
the river rolls ♪
♪ Yeah, we're born
where we're born ♪
♪ But I feel it deep down
in my bones ♪
♪ My heart beats in Tennessee ♪
♪ But my sun sets in Colorado ♪
♪ Colorado ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]